during the Revolutionary War the Second
Continental Congress drafted the
Articles of Confederation which was
ratified in 1781 the Articles of
Confederation did not give the federal
government enough power this caused some
problems for the new federal government
like the inability to levy taxes or
enforce laws in 1787 Madison and
Hamilton convinced the delegates to the
Constitutional Convention scrapped the
Articles of Confederation and draft a
new constitution that would give more
power to the federal government and
strengthen the bonds between states
anti-federalists like Patrick Henry Sam
Adams and James Monroe object they
believed that the Constitution gave too
much power to the federal government and
demanded that a Bill of Rights be added
the convention with the notable
exceptions of Edmund Randolph Elvidge
Gary and George Mason approved the
Constitution and it was ratified by the
states in 1788 in 1789
James Madison submitted a series of 39
amendments to the Constitution Congress
passed 12 and the states ratified 10 the
10 amendments now known as the Bill of
Rights were ratified in 1791
you